[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round four of the
event
that we are currently covering the start
of the grand chester in bukharesh
it's a classical event and it really
shows how different classical games are
and this game is another perfect example
because uh
there's just so much happening and it's
uh hard to imagine that um
uh well it's possible for for a
classical game where since we're all
used to now really really
a quick play you know rapid bullet blitz
and uh
well uh extreme engine preparation but
here uh as you'll see we get out of book
already on move six so without further
ado it's wesley so with the white pieces
and he opens with c4 he goes for the
english opening
uh we have e5 by fabi and now g3
uh we have knight to f6 bishop to g2 uh
fiance doing the light square bishop
bishop to c5 ending now d3 so this is
now
very very rare knight the c3 is uh well
it's a bit more
uh often played but the d3 very very
rare
uh we have c6 knight to f3 and now d6
and now
uh this position has been reached before
it was for example reaching 2019 in the
game between anishigiri and the
vishwanathan
and that game ended by giri winning and
in the game nice the c3 was played but
here
uh we just have castles by wesley and it
is already as of move six
like we announced that we have a
completely new game
so here fabi castles as well we ignite
the c3 and
now a5 grabbing more space here on the
queen side preventing any future
expansion from white so this bishop will
be very safe here
and also uh fabi is just playing uh
planning a4 and bringing the queen over
to a5 so here we have d4 uh wasted
doesn't uh wanted this spawn
to remain here so he just wants to trade
it off uh we have captures captures and
the now
a4 as planned we have rook to b1
also you you might um have to worry
about a3 at some point you don't want to
ruin your pawn structure like this so
here just rook to b1
and now a3 can always be met with a
simple b4
so here rook to e8 by fabi and now e3
we have queen to a5 and now comes bishop
to d2 so now
uh the queen is uh uh on the same
diagonal as the bishop
but uh here's a very nice idea we have
bishop to g4
attacking wesley's queen now asking do
you want to go back or do you want to
kind of mess up your pawn structure by
playing f3 and the wesley even welcomes
it he plays f3
uh attacks the bishop here with bishop
to h5 and now
knights to e4 a move that would not be
possible if the black queen wasn't
uh under attack because you just
captured the f pawn will not be able to
capture back because the queen on d1
will be hanging
so here fabi brings the queen back we
have queen to d8 and
now knight captures on c5 eliminating a
very
very strong bishop here we have d
captures on c5 and now
knight back to e2 so fabinho has a
double c
pawn but he also was able to to
kind of mess up wesley's pawn structure
here on the king side so here
queen to d3 fabi says all right uh i've
messed up your pawn structure a little
bit on the king side i'm gonna capture
the c4 pawn there's not all that much
you can do about it
and then i'm gonna also be attacking
your a2 pawn but wesley
uh prepared for this and he plays knight
to f4
he attacks the queen the bishop and it's
not a problem the bishop is defended
but what's the idea behind giving the
pawn how do you
gain compensation for that well it's
incredible how wesley does it the queen
captures on c4 and now comes
b3 and now uh the problem is the queen
doesn't have all that many squares so
you have to capture and after pawn
captures again
uh the queen doesn't have all that many
squares this is covered by the pawn this
is covered by the pawn this is covered
by the bishop by the pawn
by the knight by the knight so the only
two squares where the queen is not
captured right away is b5 and a6 or we
can even color that
differently the problem is only queen to
b5 is playable and this is what fabi
plays uh if
bobby plays queen to a6 this loses on
the spot and it's uh
just a beautiful little trick so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find a refutation for queen to a6 while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
spotting that the bishop here is kind of
hanging and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's the bishop
the c3 so congratulations to everyone
who founded this now the idea is simple
you cover the a1 square so rook to a1 is
coming but also just bishop captures on
f6
is the threat to eliminate the defender
of the bishop on h5 and you cannot
prevent both threats if you
try and save the bishop for example you
play some black knight d5 and now you
attack the bishop on c3
it's not a problem we still just play
rook to a1 and the queen gets attacked
here
so here we're gonna play bishop cap and
knight captures bishop and c3 attack
white's queen
rook captures queen we're gonna play
knight captures queen and now after rook
captures rook
uh black is simply down too much
material you can play rook d a to defend
the knight here but then you're going to
lose the bishop here and if you counted
the pieces
white is up a whole rook unless i
miscounted sometimes i miscount but
this time i did not so here white is up
a rook
so after a captures on b3 fabi plays the
only move
uh that does not lose the game and that
is queen to b5 and now comes e4
and now you can see that this is a
wesley's plan
uh fabi is now up upon but uh his queen
is a bit
out of the game his pieces are not
really developed
the rooks are not connected the knight
still needs to get into the game and
this bishop is still
not the most impressive bishop we we've
seen on this channel
so uh he brings the bishop back bishop
to g6 now the knight can move
and now bishop to c3 grabbing hold of
this long diagonal
we have knights the a6 by fabi he wants
to shift it
into the game uh somehow uh and
now h4 yeah and here fabi uh played
something uh
well a bit too premature maybe he played
h5 here
but the white uh white wasn't uh uh
threatening a move like
h5 anytime soon uh so here uh a move
like rook eight to d8 maybe to
to get the other rook into the game uh
but okay
uh he played h5 and now wesley finds
another beautiful idea and that is queen
to c1
so what do you play here uh you
constantly have to worry about knight
captures on g6 you constantly have to
worry about bishop captures on f6
so what can you play here the problem is
if you play something like rook to a
rotate the d8
now that was a great idea a moment ago
now
uh white just goes for a nice capture
fest here knight captures f captures
bishop captures g captures and now queen
to h6 now the g
pawn falls and that's it the white will
just get uh
black will just get destroyed here for
example king of seven you defend
first you deliver check and then you
pick up the g6 pawn
so instead after queen to c1 we have
king the h7 by fabi
uh but now comes rook to d1 there is no
rush
to grabbing material uh we have rook
eight to d8 and
now queen to b2 attacking the knight
here there's a double attack so we're
going to win the pawn as well and the
knight has nowhere to go so you can't
really move the knight as we're going to
lose the g7 pawn
so here we have c for by fabi now the
queen
also is uh gaining access to the fifth
rank and you are threatening to create a
pass pawn here
uh but wesley says that's not an issue
so here just bishop
captures an f6 g captures and now queen
captures an f6
so what do you play here we have rook
captures on d1 as the rook
is uh well in trouble here it's attacked
twice that's a weird arrow again
so rook captures on d1 rook captures on
d1 and now comes queen to c5 with check
the problem with creating a past pawn
here with c
captures on b3 is just rook d7 and
that's it there's no defending this
you can just capture here then capture
here or even if the rook defends the
pawn then we can even play this queen
captures and g6 as
the f pawn is pinned so uh you know
that's that's just it
so instead after rook captures on d1 we
have queen to c5 with
check fabby tries it like this king h2
and now queen to e7
offering a queen trade but now wesley
says all right uh
now i will trade queens and now i'm
gonna be up a pawn so queen captures
rook captures
and b captures on c4 so it's a classic
case of
uh going down upon gaining an extremely
active position and then to defend
fabi had to not only give back the pawn
but also give up an
extra pawn so really really impressive
how well
wesley prepared for this as uh like you
saw we had a new game
uh already as a move six but he's only
up a pawn uh it's not it's very hard to
to win this against a guy like fabi he
is the number two rated chess player in
the world in classical chess
so king to g7 and now uh bishop to h3
and bishop to h3 i don't know if for
those of you who are maybe older
subscribers to the channel i often used
to mention uh josh wadeskin when he used
to give
advice on the old chess master or or
maybe
nine or maybe 910 or the grand masters
edition
and uh there's this great chess academy
that you
if you guys can grab a hold of this
program it's uh i think it would still
be
of great use and then he said always
when you're trying to find a plan
or to you know how to uh proceed in a
certain position especially in the end
game
uh just locate your least active piece
and uh activate it or you know
improve its position so here knight is
very active the rook is very active but
the bishop
hitting its own f3 pawn is not very
reactive so here bishop to h3
another case of if you just know these
simple principles
you can find a very strong move here so
here the bishop is now
an extremely strong piece on this
diagonal and only now will you improve
the position of your king you could also
argue yes you have to play with the king
in the end game
but first we're going to improve our
stronger pieces so here
knight to c5 black does the same and now
rook to d6
and now it's very hard for black to find
a move
uh not not a lot to do here uh basically
you could
try you can't push any pawns uh because
for example this pawn hangs
you could push this pawn it's exactly
what fobby played but other than that
there are no moves here you could like
move the rook back and forth
rookie five rookie seven uh but fabi
tried an active move he played f6 but
now comes
knight to e6 with check wesley is very
happy to trade the pieces here
so knight captures uh we have bishop
captures an e6 and now
uh you don't want to allow rook to d7
the problem is you're down upon
and of course your opponent will want to
exchange rooks when you're
uh when you wrap up on you wanna uh you
want uh minor pieces on the board you
don't want rooks on the board so here
wesley would very happily trade rooks so
fabi prevents this
he doesn't allow the rook trade and now
we have c5
another beautiful endgame move uh you
want to
cement your pawns on a dark square and
lock your opponent's pawns on
lightweight so now you will be able to
attack your opponent's pawns but
your opponent's light square bishop will
not be able to attack your pawn so
that's also also very nicely done
so here at bishop to f7 uh fabio of
course wants to trade bishops and then
it's going to be able to he
he probably will be able to draw the
game uh even down upon with only rooks
on the board
but wesley of course also knows that so
he plays bishop to c8 and now he's
threatening
rook to d7 uh which will win uh more
pawns so here
there really is nothing better fabi has
to go for rook e5 he has to give up the
two points for this one pawn
and wesley grabs it bishop captures on
b7 we have rook captures on c5 and now
rook captures on c6 again wesley offers
a trade of rooks
but fabio of course declines rook b5
with bishop to a6
and now rook to beat you with check king
to g1
and now comes bishop to e8 so here fabi
will try to survive but it's two extra
pawns and there's just no surviving this
his only hope is that
uh wesley somehow messes up so here we
have rook to c5
uh putting pressure on this pawn here so
king h6 and now
king to f1 the rook is doing a good job
cutting off the king from entering the
game
uh but two extra pawns or two extra
pawns you don't really need the king
because as long as this rook is here the
rook is out of the game as well
so here bishop to d7 now comes bishop
back to e2 and now wesley will nicely
demonstrate
how you can create a wall using your
bishop and the rook to get
the white king deep into black's
position so here
we have bishop to e8 also here's a nice
trick here for example f4 opens up a
discovery here so we're going to be in
trouble so bishop to e8 fabi defends
this
and now king f2 so now rook to b3
not allowing uh the king to go deeper
into posit into the position but now
rook d5 now preparing to block uh
the rook's reach the d3 square and then
you're going to bring your king
into the game so here rook a3 not much
to do here for fabi now comes bishop to
d3
king to g7 now comes king to e3
we have rook to b3 here comes king to f4
and now
rook to b4 but it doesn't really help we
have rook to c5
and now comes bishop to f7
we have rook to c7 the rook finally gets
to the seventh rank
and now uh we will slowly but surely
bring our king uh
deeper into the position so black
prevents this he doesn't allow king to
f5 but here
wesley just played g4 and he was in this
position on move 52 that fabiano
caruana resigned the game uh as there is
nothing more to be done here
uh well for those of you who are maybe
new to chess it might seem like uh
like there's a lot more to do here but
two pawns are just
too much there there's no playing this
if it's uh like maybe if it was a
bishops of opposite colors you would
still have a chance maybe you can
trick your opponent into trading rooks
and then you might be able to draw
but with bishops of same color not not
happening and especially the white king
is
more active so to give you a a quick
example of how the game might continue
for example black might
trade here and then he has to wait waste
a move he doesn't have a good move he
can play
and now you can just start pushing your
pawn h5 with check king h6 now you can
just go rook c6
threaten the pawn and if the king
defends it now you can again
push your pawn h6 check king captures
you're gonna play
g5 check now the pawn cannot capture its
pin so you have to move f captures and
now you have two connected past pawns
and it's a very very easy win from there
so yeah after g4 a beautiful
victory by wesley so and it's not every
day someone
defeats the the world number two in
classical chess
i'm pretty sure i could be wrong last
time i remember
it happened was in i'm it could be even
20 20 19.
uh i'm probably wrong but last game i
remember was him losing the the
classical game
uh to peter leko in bundesliga where
elekko
i had the white pieces fabi played that
weird the queen's gambit declined with
with asics on the fourth move but uh i'm
probably wrong but i i can't remember
fabi losing a classical game after that
but yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
uh frank claudius
gregoire schiller michael hildebrand
steven mcgill
and mario and sinosa for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day